Bell Labs got its first actual laser
printer in 1982 which I think was from a
company called Imogen now in those days
yet you could get them but the big
problem the big big problem was fonts it
wasn't my any means impossible to get
laser printer technology at lower
resolution than the Omnitech was doing
more reliable in knotting them if we
asked for a price I think for an imaging
early laser printer and we were told it
will be $18,000 in the UK which would
have translated to about 15,000 pounds
it's ridiculously expensive if you're
getting to lower resolutions like 300
dots per inch what then happens is that
your eyes are sensitive enough to notice
roughnesses on the edge of the character
in other words the pixel density of 300
dpi is such that if something goes wrong
in terms of the pattern of pixels and
you get a fault at the edge of the
character your eyes notice it at 972 DPR
they probably wouldn't notice at all so
the burning question was how can we do
this
rounding problem if you like we've got
these beautiful outlines we need to
translate them into dot patterns how do
you work out which pixels to turn on
which to turn off and if you've got half
a pixel by the time you've done your
calculations do you turn it on and you
turn it off and of course you can
imagine what happens it looks bad if you
didn't turn that pixel on it looks even
worse if you did turn it on you just
couldn't win it was a huge problem and
within the industry there was the most
ferocious debate with with in Xerox
cannon wherever and even many of you
know the computer scientists who got
involved around about this time with
typesetting donkey death and the
consensus was that down at low
resolution you just had to have
hand-tuned bitmap fonts with all the
pixels put in place correctly there was
no shortcut
there was no way that you could if you
like on the fly scale down from outlines
to docks on a drum and get it right
automatically hand tuning was the way
forward well if that was the case it was
a real mess because it meant that your
laser printer had to be backed up with
an expensive hard disk or cartridge
system and some commenters already on
the jailbreak system of use these of say
what a nightmare it was you had a very
restricted range of fonts they never
seemed to work correctly and that whole
disk instead of a holding 50 or 60
different typefaces was devoted to
holding times roman and tuned in about
40 usable point sizes stuff like that
the thing that kept us going though the
room is on the horizon if you like where
that to people working for Xerox PARC
called Warnock and gaskey were about to
leave Xerox PARC and form a new company
called Adobe now the Mon you say Xerox
PARC you start thinking we need a
complete new video just on that alone
Park Parc Palo Alto Research Center
if Bell Labs was the one place that
everybody wanted to work at in the 1970s
then Xerox PARC was certainly the other
and there was a similar background in
some ways and Bell Labs had lots and
lots of money because of AT&T but of
course they were under consistent
scrutiny for firm monopolistic practices
and don't you ever dare turn yourselves
into a computer company it wouldn't be
allowed Xerox probably didn't have quite
as much money as Bell Labs but
nevertheless even today Izzy rocks I
think turns over about twenty billion
dollars a year so they could afford a
vanity project and they did the Xerox
Palo Alto Research Center was run off
the Xerox publicity budget that's how
much money
Xerox were making we still do make
just being a photocopier company but at
Xerox PARC they invented either invented
or had a very strong development role in
all sorts of things that are now
commonplace the computer mouse the laser
printer bitmapped terminals which we
take for granted nowadays but if you
skip back to my earlier video on from
mainframes to Unix just take a look at
what the old character terminals used to
be like sort of cells of dots about nine
by nine where the characters in here
certainly couldn't get down to the bit
level on your screen but with bitmap
terminals you could they had under
development at Xerox PARC things with
names like Alto and Dorado bitmap
terminals wonderful and they had Bob
Metcalfe there they were crucially
involved in the development of Ethernet
they had it all they had all the
necessary components to pioneer the next
stage of computing if you like the
workstation revolution but in a book I
think called fumbling the future the
author of that book makes the case that
they fumbled it they let it all fall
they didn't market it and they could
have done well to prefer to Xerox at the
time you could argue they made the right
decision turning yourself into a
computer company is hard to do if you're
not a computer company already and
wonderful though their technology was it
was reckoned at the time that the cost
of the components alone in mid-1970s
money to make an Alto terminal the
components alone would have cost ten
thousand dollars if they were mad enough
to go into marketing the thing they
would have had to charge at least
$25,000 in 1975 money probably about two
hundred fifty thousand dollars in
today's money so you could say in a
sense they had to wait for the cost of
the technology to come down and they had
to accept that all these toys were very
very expensive indeed now the only
problem was was sitting on and
developing all this wonderful technology
was that a hotshot computer scientist
you've got working for you got very
frustrated that they're wonderful
inventions and developments were not
being marketed and so gradually as the
seventies wore on into the 80s people
began to leave and form their own
startups Chuck cash key John Warnock
both considerable computer scientists in
their own right we're working on Xeroxes
into press language and just got so
frustrated with Xeroxes inability a lack
of will to market this properly that
they up sticks left and formed Adobe
which you've all heard of in late 1982
I think they initially decided that they
were going to go for the high-end
typesetting market soon after they left
and founded Adobe John Warnock got to
work on a language that's achieved great
Fame ever since called PostScript I
think it very carefully avoided the
precise way that inter press had done
things and it reverted back to lots of
John's earlier work because he was a
computer graphics specialist who came
out of the University of Utah and also
worked for the graphics company called
Heather Evans & Sutherland and in his
PhD and solved the infamous hidden
surface problem which had defied
efficient solution for quite some time I
think I've already told you in the video
I did about David Huffman and Huffman
trees his PhD thesis was 12 pages I
think John told me that his PhD thesis
about solving the hidden surface problem
was a little bit bigger all of 32 pages
so here was this computer scientist a
computer graphics expert joined up with
another considerable computer scientist
Chuck cash key it was the ideal
combination to found this new company
John came up with this language called
PostScript which was going to be a tour
de force of two-dimensional graphics and
it was and more to the point he was
going to get to grips with solving this
problem of how to make fonts look good
at low resolutions you want to hold the
outline of the fountas arcs splines
lines
ever for as long as possible but in the
end it has got to get down to being
pixels it's got to be dots on and laser
printer drum and in fact there's some
other stuff of course John Chapman's
videos on computer files so relevant to
this you really ought to watch them so
here's some more detail which relates to
that or by the way thanks to font Agra
fir those of you want to know how I did
the so called print out font in the
jailbreak video
I think the papers that we web link to
make this player but anyway I use
photographer and within the font Agra
for manual there is a very useful pair
of pages which makes very clear this
difficulty with getting characters to
look good on a coarse resolution
consider a letter H here's the outline
superimposed on top of a grid of pixels
now how do you decide which pixels of
these vertical stems to be colored in if
you follow the argument that a pixel
should be made black only if it's
totally within the outline then if your
outline isn't quite as helpfully aligned
with the pixels as it might be this is
what you end up with on the left hand
side the only ones that are totally
within the outline is a single column
whereas on this side there's two columns
if you back off take away the grid of
pixels at the back and look at what the
character looks like it's awful you know
you've got uneven stem widths and do
notice in these of course the crossbar
is gone on the H isn't that wonderful of
course it would go it's so thin in that
desire in that design it's been rounded
down and it's vanished completely here's
another thing even if you could solve
that these flicky bits as we know are
the tops and bottoms of characters I
think probably everybody knows they
called serifs well you need your service
to look good as well and if you're not
careful you can end up with the stems
getting better and more equal
but the seraphs having no symmetry
whatsoever even though they're supposed
to be the same shay
the precise way they aligned with the
grid underneath is such that they don't
look symmetrical anymore whereas they
were in the first instance and then you
can say oh could we solve all of this by
saying well tell you what we'll turn the
pixel on if any part of it touches the
outline however glancing if you like the
impact is between the pixels in the
outline if it's at all remotely touching
turn it on and that's the kind of mess
you end up with if you do that so what
you needed was a system of what came to
be known as hints on the diagrams here
for the letter M hints show all the
places in which the Adobe type 1 font
system actually said mattered hints
about the seraphs these are important
take care
hints about horizontal lines like on the
age don't round it down and don't have
it disappear altogether within the font
mechanism it was basically when you are
scaling down the outline and as john
chapman videos will also show you in the
end although you can delay doing a
straight line approximation to Kurs in
the end that's what you do you end up
with triangles and polygons ok and then
those triangles and polygons you work
out where they intersect with the
underlying pixels and so on so later on
in the process and this is the advantage
of this more modern approach compared to
the 202 rather faster processes you can
leave the as it were translation into
straight line approximations and pixels
until the latest possible moment thereby
giving yourself flexibility now this
shows you this is Linotype 202
resolution up at the top that is the
base I think of a stem of a matter H or
I or something like that it something
more like 970 dot C and you see there's
no problem to back off from that your
eyes are probably not sensitive enough
to notice the odd pixel that's gone
astray but down at 300 dpi they
certainly will and of course the problem
manifests itself hugely a trend
dpi if you have small point sizes like
six point or eight point you end up if
you're not careful with everything
looking just like a full stop because
there's been so many errors so this is
why you need these hints you need stem
hints you need serif hints you need
hints to stop horizontal things
vanishing all together due to rounding
down John Warner was the recipient of a
very prestigious medal called a Lovelace
medal and my friend Conrad Taylor has
done a report on that talk which is
happy for us to use and in Connor as a
report you will see that John Warnock
actually admitted 20 years after the
event that there was another dirty trick
that they did as well as if you like as
part of the hint that they didn't let on
about if you look back at this diagram
here and how it translates to turned on
pixels here although we will enrage the
type designers there is a way that you
can help yourself here type designers
like calling the gap to the left of a
character the left side bearing and the
gap at the right of the carrot to the
right sign bearing now if you look
carefully the left side bearing here is
absolutely wider than the right side
there this is part of the design you
position your character within the cell
so it looks right in all combinations
with all other characters and even in a
fixed-width font like printout of the
previous video you found a left or right
sign bearings are still not equal yeah
but what John and his Merry Men did if
their type worn renderer was to say
actually although they designer will
kill us they probably won't notice if at
the very last minute we just shove the
letter H ever so slightly further left
okay so that's instead of ending up with
a one pixel line and a two pixel line
you might end up with both of them being
one and a half because you've made
the alignment of the character against
the background grid beat just much more
sympathetic and if he's one and a half
it doesn't matter whether you round both
sides 2:1 or round them up to 2 they are
at least going to be equal okay that's
going to help a lot so he actually
admitted in 2004 that it was not beyond
them to ever so subtly shift the
character within its unit cell to get a
better alignment and a better result so
that is then pretty well a summary of
what had to be done what had to be got
right with hinting before if you like
quality fonts stood any hope of working
properly with laser printers John
Warnock bought the PostScript language
effectively into the public domain and
said gone implemented I want it to be a
standard you know implementation is the
sincerest form of flattery as one of the
first implementers said but the story
was this you can use all the graphics
operators in PostScript you could do a
pretty acceptable form that way but it
was what Adobe called at the time a type
3 font it did not have these hints to
enable you to survive and make it look
good down at very small point sizes on
low resolution devices if you wanted
that then back in 1980 from about 1985
to 1989 you had to sign a contract with
Adobe to license their hinting
technology and this was secret this was
one of the ways that Adobe as a young
company wanted to make money they were
selling post group implementations of
course you are the printer manufacturers
but there's a nice font revenue stream
from licensing people to put type 1
hints onto Adobe type 1 fonts so there
we are then there's another story to
come here but we'll get onto that later
about how Adobe survived with that model
for about four or five years but
eventually gates and jobs were not gonna
pay endless royalties for type 1 - John
Warnock dearly though they loved it
and we could do a talk at some stage
about the emergence of TrueType out of
that but for the moment here's the story
then you needed a laser printer equipped
with PostScript but with PostScript plus
the ability to cope with type 1 fonts
and do be clear this hinting information
things like these stems should be of the
same width that cross bar on the H don't
round it down and don't lose it this is
used at the very last moment when you're
converting things into pixels on the
imaging drum and it's ultra ultra
important that you get it right but
effectively John and his Merry Men with
PostScript had and the hinting had
solved a problem which many people in
the industry said was insoluble you know
there isn't a way to take out lines and
round them down to all point sizes and
make it look good well you might say
that some of the tricks that John did
were compromises and were a little bit
short of perfection but frankly even to
type professionals I don't know if you
did an A and B you know hand-tuned
bitmap h versus what the Adobe type one
mechanism did with that H okay with a
good microscope you notice the
difference but for everyday use no
problem at all if the problem was solved
essentially
you
of here a reproduction of our party
piece that we used to do for people on
the 202 can you imagine that in
beautiful fresh and gleaming bromide the
next thing you do this is great fun is
to decorate the tree I now want to from
this work out what the correct code the
minimal code should be for a given State